so uh my mom got cancer um at the age of
58 she had lung cancer um just clearing
her throat
and when she was visiting me and she's
i'm like get that check never smoked a
day in her life was diagnosed lung
cancer never smoked never smoked oh my
god [ __ ] cancer it was it was awful and
then like a week after she
um got diagnosed lung cancer they found
the brain tumors and so she she had nine
months and she was a really like just a
selfless woman she was a paralegal my
stepfather was an engineer and they just
gave to us all the time in terms of like
the work ethic and if you want to own
something you have to earn it so my mom
died and it was devastating for me and
it just really
like made me question everything in life
and a couple years later my stepfather
was downsized he just couldn't he never
went into the bedroom after she died and
and he was just devastated when she died
so
i found this unfinished bucket list when
i was helping him move and it was my
mom's list that she had always wanted to
do now for herself for herself and she'd
always talked about i mean as kids you
know we would always look through the
national geographic magazines and it was
all these crazy things like see the
seven wonders of the world climate
kilimanjaro mount fuji and
it's not like i grew up i grew up in
pennsylvania out in the country but like
we didn't go hiking as a family now we
went cross-country in a van and slept in
that for three weeks but we didn't do
all these crazy things but she'd always
wanted to um
and so i just had this epiphany like i
have to finish her list and spread her
ashes to all the places she didn't get
to go to
and
it took me about a couple years then to
get to that spot where i was ready to
leave my whole life i mean at that time
i was you know had the big corporate job
my my husband at the time you know he
was a chief technology officer in new
york city um we had the big house in
north jersey jag bmw
and you know who does that who just
leaves it yeah and i talked to my
husband like hey let's do mom's list for
a couple years and just leave all this
and he's like no i'm climbing the
corporate ladder like why would i do
what are you crazy my family thought i
was crazy too and i was like well i'm
doing it so we got divorced i sold
everything i owned and completely
downsized and like took off but also
understand that her mom taught her about
investments
at like 13 years old when i was 18 she
marched me into merle lynch and she's
like you're gonna learn how to invest
your money i've been working since i was
12. you know put herself through college
and her mba
yeah so you know we again mom's thing
was you have to own it to earn it you
have to earn it to own it so
i was really good when i took off like i
didn't have any debt like i never had
any college loans but i worked my ass
off through college to pay for it to
make sure i didn't have any debt my mom
was one that was old school where i
remember her having the envelopes for
the grocery bill or for gas and so um
that was probably the best lesson one of
the best lessons she's ever taught me so
you're not a slave to all those things
so i wound up researching like how do
you climb mountains what kind of gear
and apparel do you need and i took off
and created a website called
turnthepage.com so my family and friends
would know where i was going
and how long ago was this by the way i
started in 2007. oh wow okay yeah so
just in time
um and
yeah and i took you know first few years
were really fast like i did a lot of the
bucket list things like i first what i
did was i went to machu picchu and i
couldn't just show up like from the
train in agua caliente in peru i had to
backpack the inca trail like i had to
earn that experience that's part of what
she taught me and so from there i went
to rome and um
from her ashes the coliseum and then i
flew down to tanzania and climbed my
kilimanjaro and then from there you know
just kept going and going and
[Music]
you